all right this was the catch we did the
other day so I'm here you have your
extension there and then your
[Music]
is don't try to turn
them straight gear
[Music]
straight okay try it okay so go go
really really slow okay so I don't want
to bend my elbows like this and then
have my hand outside my outer rim over
here
I have to use the
my to keep my arms in
C okay so
my I can maybe go back youing and make
that
worse Bo make it worse you can add
curves to it make it work there's all
kinds of things
I don't not like
[Music]
this okay try it
again and then both hands are so here's
the C you had you
see both hands are controlling they're
not kind of loose here I'm not fighting
him and then or I push here and this
hand is
loose so my right hand k your hand is
touching the left hand is it's
touching touch feel
both both
hands both hands both hands
don't cut down you're going to lose
it okay try it
again like that you have to bring them
up then you have it
Bo the S has toar them
up okay so you can't keep them
down you're not going to pick them
up you see here like this this hand's
going that
way this hand don't keep it down he
can't he's just going to stay there you
let him turn there right there
[Music]
try it again don't check him if you want
him to come up okay don't pin him try it
again
this time low this time pushy here she
on
and try